well um i've been thinking about
jon jones um
he has he's gotten in trouble again this
time he was abusing his wife he's got
for for those who are listening who
don't know who jon jones is maybe you
don't know martial arts he's you know
considered one of the best
martial artists like really of all time
which is which is crazy um he's in the
ufc
hasn't been active in a long time
and
he's a very very troubled individual and
he just recently
uh was elected or
not elected um
hall of fame right he was he was
inducted yes inducted into the hall of
fame for one of his fights i can't
remember which would you know off it was
the one with gustafson okay so
um he had just gotten his award he
you know went back to the hotel told his
wife that yeah in vegas of course that
actually really matters in this one okay
so in vegas told his wife hey i'm gonna
go out i'm taking ten thousand dollars
uh i'm gonna go out
comes back they get in an argument at
like five in the morning he hits her she
goes down to the lobby the security
guard notices the blood on her face
because she asks to change
the room right it was a cry for help it
was a well she that's actually true she
didn't want to go back to the room with
him
i think she wanted a different or wait
did she want to lock him out i think she
wanted to lock him out so by changing
the key he wouldn't have been able to
get back in
and she went down and the one of the
daughters was there with her
yes and i think you know that also could
have been like a hey i'm
i'm in trouble like i'm scared type of
thing
also right it's
a lot of people said the wife said can
we just get a new room key and the guy
mentioned do you need
any assistance and she kind of said no
but she also said that she didn't want
to go back up and then it was the
daughter
the daughter was the one that said can
you call the police
right yes yes [ __ ]
i know that was that i think that was
the the chill video that you sent me
that was the the the part that really
it makes the heads on the back of your
neck stand up like yeah your own
daughter
is calling the police on you to stop you
from hitting her mother yeah like so
crazy so he's a very very very troubled
man and we can talk about like
you know what he should do or shouldn't
do or what should happen
but something that's very interesting to
me is
um
this was something that
daniel cormier who's now uh you know an
analyst and
uh you know just a a figurehead at the
ufc
um he was a
heavyweight champion or super
heavyweight champion
uh in the ufc i don't know he defended
it a couple times he lost the belt got
it back
but um
he had a few fights with jon jones and
one of the things that he said in his
interview
he ended up kind of predicting the
future and i'll just play the clip um
i'll play the audio here i want to hear
my reaction please he doesn't want to
hear my reaction because i will tell him
some sober and truth please sober and
truth is his history dictates and
determines
that the same thing is going to happen
that is his character that is him at his
core i look at that young lady the pr
lady that's on his team now and i see in
her eyes she knows she's fighting a
losing battle i look at his coaches i
see that these guys know that this kid
will not change he won't he will not
change he's the same guy he's rotten at
his core and he will continue
don't you think that people can learn
from their mistakes mistakes
mistakes
you don't constantly make mistakes no
you make mistakes but you don't do them
over and over and over and over and over
you don't do that if you know when a
mistake when you make a mistake it
changes you try to make yourself better
and this many times we've heard this
speech jonathan pretty
unbelievable that he gave me the chills
so that was i believe two years ago
and john had already been in a lot of
trouble and
dc says he's rotten at his core and he
is bound to repeat history will repeat
itself with this man
and look at what we're doing we're
talking about this
i thought that that was the most
effective like i i have not seen
something like that that would to me
that was chilling
and what i wanted to talk about
with you chris is
what
well i guess first let's talk about
redemption for someone like jon jones
and my theory is that he has to almost
he has to let go of his identity
completely
he has to do penance you know whatever
that is if he has to go to jail whatever
that is you know
um if that's monetary
but he has to lose his identity as a
fighter and as a party goer and has to
change his his life entirely in order to
recover from this and
you know this type of behavior for
someone in the real world someone who
doesn't have the money that jon jones
does doesn't have the fame and notoriety
that jon jones does
this type of behavior leads to jail time
leads to death leads to other people he
was some normal black man out in the
world of america he's [ __ ] oh a
hundred percent so my thing is this is
like if he is to move on from this it
has to be a complete and utter spiritual
and mental psychological change
from from where he has to go from there
the second so so the second part i want
to talk about is
what determines
whether someone is a good man or a bad
man
based on their actions how many actions
does it take
is redemption possible at all the time
does does redemption become harder to to
get
uh the more you [ __ ] up
and that's that's what i'm curious about
someone like jon jones is like i even
though this position that he's in right
now even though i still like to think
that there's a
potential for redemption at least within
himself
how old's jon jones
i'm not i'm not entirely sure has thirty
bro
there's no there is no time for him to
turn his life around
and come back how many chances is this
guy being given
didn't he get he got popped for some
sort of pds like yeah if you want to
tick off
all of the big things that you shouldn't
do as an athlete whether it be
recreational drugs whether it be
performance enhancing drugs whether it
be getting into misdemeanors he
hit a pregnant woman in his car he shot
a gun outside of the window of one of
his cars he was belligerent to the
police when he got arrested this time
after this incident with his misses and
he had the cuffs on behind his back
apparently turned to the four police
officers and said i'd love to see if you
four like [ __ ] could take me on your
own if you undid these handcuffs i've
just been inducted into the hall of fame
then he headbutted the police car so
he's now got to pay for the damages to
the police car so like the guys are
developing
what i'm saying
of course what i'm saying is though is
like that whole being a fighter thing is
gone like in my opinion to be an uh to
come back maybe i mean who knows in this
weird world we live in
you know like o.j simpson is one step
away from getting a celebrity boxing
match like that's how [ __ ] weird this
world is is he okay i don't know you
know it's like
you never know what can happen you know
what i'm saying though right like
jake paul logan paul all this stuff
they're they're headlining they're
they're big martial artists now like
it's it's crazy
what i was thinking more along the lines
of like jon jones just disappears
just disappears out of the limelight
and changes who he is i think in order
to
that's already happened so people
mentioned this they said a few years ago
jon jones could lord it over people like
danny because one of the reasons that he
said he wasn't going to come back is
because he wanted to get paid a million
dollars for a fight and the ufc
don't seem to be quite good with fight
to pay that's a big criticism that they
often get
so john said i'm going to wait because i
can hold out because i can negotiate he
forgets man this fought this sport moves
so fast i don't [ __ ] need jon jones
anymore the sport doesn't know they
don't they haven't needed him in the
heavyweight division for a long time and
he continues to [ __ ] up and continues to
be out of the game
so
i i don't see where his leverage comes
from with regards to that i don't think
that people care i don't think the ufc
need him i don't think the world need
him like if you're not going to be a
good athlete what you can be is a good
ambassador or a good role model for
people to look up to young kids you know
let's say the cormiers of the world like
yeah cowboy cerrone
the guy retired at the peak of his
career
so he's no longer an athlete in the mma
uh in the ufc but he can be a really
good ambassador for people to look up to
jon jones has [ __ ] both of those
things he's no longer an athlete yeah
andy's not a role model for people to
look up to i don't want my future kids
to be looking up to jon jones as the
sort of athlete that they should try and
aspire to be [ __ ] that so yeah in terms
of that correct and then in terms of how
much redemption you need
how much you would need to do to undo
all of the bad work
i don't think anyone can
i don't i would always try and give
somebody the opportunity to try and
achieve redemption i don't think that
anybody can be a lost cause apart from
like psychopaths and people that are in
prison and rapists and stuff like that
yes and that's what i mean is like
i think a lot of times people want
redemption fast because that's how the
world works now
right it's like i want to be back in the
limelight but i want to be in your good
uh on your good side and what's missing
there is the penance what's missing
there is the shame
and given what given jon jones's past
that shame and that penance that that
has to take years i mean i would say
this chris as much as you would say
there's no possible way this man could
redeem himself
what about 10 years from now
but what does 10 years from now and
i don't i'm i'm not entirely sure and
that's why i it's interesting to me i
like to talk about things like this
because these are things that are almost
outside of the scope of human nature is
like long-term
feelings about someone else
i have this feeling that
people want to be on the winning side
so
for instance if if you
[ __ ] up
i want to naturally be on your side
outside of being my friend someone i
care about
i want you to be on top of whatever that
is i want you to come out
on the on the good side of that because
it i want to be a winner too you know
it's like and that's not like a it
sounds very self-indulging but i'm not
trying to be it's like
i think people want redemption i think
people want kind of you mean you they
want people to achieve redemption
i think so so i think so you may be
right man but there's only so many times
that you can of course let that happen
you know the cheating boyfriend in the
relationship
the wife might be able to take him back
the first time or the second time or
whatever but after five times you go
this isn't a misdemeanor that requires
redemption this is an inbuilt part of
your nature
this is just you
and here's another thing i think that
where you're coming at this from is
maybe the same as me which is
an inherent belief that people are good
an inherent hope that people are here to
try and be good people like to
contribute to society in a way that's
[ __ ] constructive and leave the world
in a better place than they found it
i think we need to concede that there
are some people out there who don't do
that like there are some people who
simply if you leave them in the world
for long enough
they're going to continue to make it a
worse and worse and worse place
yeah and like the
the crazy thing about all this is like
this position that i'm playing right now
it's just a position that i'm curious
about i'm thinking through it
this is not how you know what i mean and
i just want the listeners and viewers to
kind of understand that
i i
like to think about things from from a
lens that i may not think about in real
life you know when it happens
i've been [ __ ] over you've been [ __ ]
over i'm sure both of us have [ __ ]
over some people um and
they have every right and you have every
right and i have every right to move on
from that person
um
but i still like to think about the
potential for someone to make some sort
of a comeback and you know this is just
a thought cause like
jesus jon jones really has [ __ ] up the
most
of anyone in his sport
that i can even think of here's a
question for you
is it still acceptable to call jon jones
the goat when he behaves privately
in the way that we've seen can you
separate the art and the artist
no i i i never called him that
and basically because of that
so you think that you know joe rogan had
no
it's
it's very weird now we're talking about
morality and
ability all right so fighting talent in
the in the octagon is he the greatest of
all time
well
i don't i don't know
possibly who's it possibly
it would be
between him
i think khabib
uh we're looking at valentina chefchanko
who's doesn't seem like she's gonna lose
anytime soon
um who else would be on that list
a lot of it has to do with title
defenses i think that's one of the
criticisms that khabib gets right that
who did he fight
that he did a title defense against that
was actually world class whereas jon
jones pretty much everyone that he did a
title defense against was world cup yes
right
um and then also
conor mcgregor didn't have many title
defenses if any did he have any none
right i think that was his main
criticism too
but
um yeah you know i
i don't know it was just very very
strange and and the whole thing is eerie
dude it's just like
something needs to change like what what
would you do if you were john jones's
friend if he has any friends i don't
even i think i would have given up by
now
yeah i think that i get quite personally
invested in my friends and in their
well-being right and after a while after
it depends how long if you've only just
become friends with him this week then
maybe you've got a bit of tolerance left
in the tank
but yeah i would have um
right
there's only so far that you can try and
take people and it's like like man like
this is your [ __ ] i would have tried to
have an intervention i would have tried
to sit down with him or try to do
whatever it seems very much like he's
hugely narcissistic like he has very
little empathy for other people oh of
course yeah with all of those things
piled together it's like look man this
is your [ __ ] problem if you're big
enough to hit a woman you're big enough
to get yourself out of all of these
messes that you got yourself into
so
yeah thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe makes me very happy
indeed
peace
you